from buzzworthy biopics to high-profile
action thrillers Netflix is rewarding
into 2023. here are 25 of the most
anticipated films coming our way on
Netflix this year
after finding critical success with
2020's extraction director Sam Hargrave
is back along with the Russo Brothers
with extraction 2. due to hit Netflix
sometime in 2023 extraction 2 will again
focus on Chris Hemsworth's Tyler rake a
Black Ops mercenary tasked with a life
or death Mission with a title of who
behind your name you have to bring at
least twice the action
extraction was refreshing entry in the
action genre and Hemsworth delivered a
career-defining performance for which he
received praise from audiences and
critics alike the film became one of
Netflix's most watched Originals ever
reaching 99 million households in its
first month on the streaming service
but best things submerged in it
besides Hemsworth a definitive cast list
hasn't been made public though golshifty
ferhani is set to reprise her role of
Nick Khan Tyler's partner no release
date has been pinned down but filming is
said to have wrapped last April it's
been 23 years since Peter Lord and Nick
Park created chicken run a triumphant
piece of stop-motion animation Chicken
Run Remains the highest grossing
stop-motion film ever raking in over 227
million dollars at the box office check
and run dawn of the Nugget was greenlit
in 2018 by Studio canal and Netflix
acquired the rights in 2020. the film
will focus on Ginger and her friends
after they escape tweedy's Farm is it as
good as you imagine
Jane Horrocks Imelda Stuntin and Lynn
Ferguson are the only original actors to
reprise their roles from the first movie
but given the critical response to the
first film we should expect another
brilliant entertaining story from Lord
and park adaptations of books by
renowned children's author Roald Dahl
have often become movie classics
beginning with 1971's Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory all the way to
Roald Dahl's The Witches in 2020 doll's
work has been a linchpin in cinema for
five decades in 2021 Netflix acquired
the rights to the Roald Dahl story
company paying over 680 million dollars
for the author's bibliography first up
is the wonderful story of Henry Sugar
helmed by acclaimed director Wes
Anderson published in 1977 the wonderful
story of Henry sugar follows sugar a
gambler who dares to use meditation to
count cards Anderson's adaptation will
explore the destruction of greed that
doll's adult skewed fairy tale examined
with Benedict Cumberbatch set to play
sugar and a Supporting Cast of Rey finds
Dev Patel and Ben Kingsley the wonderful
story of Henry sugar should be a
marvelous entry in the doll Cinematic
Universe
though it hit theaters for a limited
release on December 23rd Scott Cooper's
the pale blue eye was the first original
movie to stream on Netflix in 2023.
Netflix seems to be starting the year
off with a lot of corpses and
conspiracies the pale blue eye doesn't
skimp on brutality which adds another
layer of Darkness to Cooper's period
piece it is whodunit it's a fictional
story about a series of murders that
take place at West Point set in 1830 the
pale blue eye follows Augustus Landor
played by Christian Bale as he
investigates murders within the U.S
military alongside a young Edgar Allan
Poe played by Harry melling with enough
patience a suspect will offer
interrogate himself the movie is based
on Lewis bayard's 2003 novel of the same
name and has a terrific cast that
includes Jillian Anderson and Robert
Duvall among many other standouts fans
of the Beverly Hills Cop franchise have
been waiting 28 years for another
installment and in 2023 their time will
finally come Beverly Hills Cop Axel
Foley marks another turn in Murphy's
ongoing career Renaissance hoping to
capitalize on the Acclaim he received
for his performances in Dolomite is my
name and coming to America audiences can
only hope that the comedian can slip
back into the Persona of his most
beloved character yes you have a
reservation for an Axel Foley the story
follows Axel as he comes back to Beverly
Hills to sniff out corruption in his old
police department can you put this in a
good spot it's all this happened
last time I parked here many of the
franchise's original cast including
Judge Reinhold and Bronson Pinchot are
set to return while Taylor Page Kevin
Bacon and Joseph Gordon-Levitt will take
on brand new characters Beverly Hills
Cop has a storied Legacy with the
original film consistently labeled as
one of the funniest movies ever made so
Beverly Hills Cop Axel Foley has a lot
to live up to it'll be exciting to see
the old gang back in action for the
first time in almost 30 years
not much is known about the film
adaptation of mattkin's comic book
series Department H though it's set to
hit Netflix sometime this year Alice
Waddington is slated to direct the film
her first credit since her feature debut
Paradise Hills in 2019. Department H
revolves around Mia a special
investigator hired to derail a
saboteur's plan at a deep sea research
facility the series traverses a long
complicated crime scene that plays out
like a nautical game of Clue where
suspects must prove their innocence
while surviving against the creatures
surrounding them how Waddington will
condense Kent's work into one feature
film will be something worth keeping
note of no cast list has yet been
released kin series ran for almost two
full years given that the comic doesn't
have the biggest fan base that leaves
the door wide open for Waddington to
make the source material her own it's
one of the most anticipated Netflix
releases and comic book adaptations of
in one of Netflix's most high-profile
releases of 2023 Tom Harper's Heart of
Stone has garnered a lot of attention
thanks to its illustrious cast which
includes Gal Gadot and Jimmy Dornan in
the leading roles Heart of Stone will be
Harper's first directorial effort since
the aeronauts in 2019. the story
revolves around Rachel Stone a CIA agent
navigating altercations with dangerous
Global Powers Rachel Stone lifts off the
adrenaline she's addicted to it most of
the plot is being kept Under Wraps we
just know that it's a spy action
thriller Sofio Canada schweigafer Jing
Lucy and Alia Bhatt are set to play
supporting roles
written directed and starring Jerry
Seinfeld unfrosted the Pop-Tarts story
as one of Netflix's most anticipated
comedies of the upcoming year Seinfeld
has directed before including episodes
of his own show Comedians and Cars
Getting Coffee and two of Colin Quinn's
stand-up specials Netflix won the rights
to the film in 2021 the premise of which
stems from Seinfeld's own joke about the
Pop-Tarts Inception they can't go stale
because they were never fresh in the
story two breakfast serial Titans
Kellogg's and post duke it out competing
to make the first ever mass-produced
breakfast pastry in the Vietnam War era
Midwest unfrosted has an Olympic level
cast signed on already including Melissa
McCarthy Amy Schumer and Bobby Moynihan
to name just a few it's like 15 stand-up
comics are in this what will come of a
film brimming with some of the 21st
Century's greatest comedians you know in
my world the wrong or something feels
the writer it is
in what will be his second release
through Netflix within a year Jonah Hill
has teamed up with blackish Creator
Kenya Barris to make you people Hill and
bears co-wrote the script together the
film examines the intersection of
culture disparities with Modern Love
plus a sprinkling of generational issues
added to the mix as Hill and Lauren
London play an interracial couple
meeting each other's families for the
first time so do you hang out in the
hood all the time or do you just come up
here for our food and women as Hill and
London's in-laws to be are Eddie Murphy
Nia Long Julia Louis Dreyfus and David
Duchovny considering barris's success
with blackish and Hill's ability to
perfectly blend comedy and drama you
people are shaping up to be one of the
most intriguing releases of 2023
Netflix's catalog in 2023 won't be short
of action films though Havoc might end
up being one of the streamer's best of
the Year directed by Gareth Evans who
last helmed Apostle in 2018 Havoc will
Mark the first non-venom performance by
Tom Hardy since Capone in 2020. Havoc
focuses on the aftermath of a bad drug
deal when Hardy's detective character
Walker must survive within the dark
underbelly of crime in his City Walker
is tasked with saving the kidnapped son
of a high-ranking politician while
watching his home unravel from The Vices
of greed and Corruption as with many of
Netflix's upcoming releases Havoc has a
promising cast highlighted by Forest
Whitaker Timothy Oliphant Justin
Cornwell and Jesse May Lee Evans is a
relatively unproven director but this
film could completely change all that
Hardy is an exemplary leading man so
Havoc shouldn't have any trouble finding
its audience especially viewers who are
fans of Netflix's Blockbuster action
flick extraction
director Ross and Marshall Thurber has
been tapped to helm Netflix's new
dystopian Thriller the division it's his
first credit since red notice in 2021
although he's perhaps best known for
directing the comedy's dodgeball A True
Underdog Story and We're the Millers the
division details how a futuristic fast
spreading buyers is being contracted
through people handling paper money the
events reach an apex on Black Friday the
biggest shopping day of the year in New
York City what unfolds is the
dissolution of society amid a great
viral catastrophe in which the fate of
the country rests in the hands of
civilians who must fight against
bioterrorists while the government races
to find a cure as of right now the only
cast members confirmed are Jessica
Chastain and Jake Gyllenhaal Chastain
and Gyllenhaal are two of the most
reliable leading actors working in
Hollywood right now so the division
should be a thrilling story to watch
Step Up all In and Pitch Perfect 3
director Trish c's next film is the
romantic comedy players due to hit
Netflix in late 2023 Netflix hasn't let
too many cats out of the bag about
players all we know is that it's a
rom-com with the sports fan slant a
sports writer Mack after years of flings
and hookups meets a woman who inspires
him to settle down and go all in on a
relationship Tom Ellis and Jane the
Virgin star Gina Rodriguez are slated to
play the movie's leads while Damon
Wayans Jr Brock O'Hearn and Joel
Courtney will take on supporting roles
the last time we saw Ellis was in his
leading role on Lucifer while Rodriguez
was in the Amazon Prime hit rom-com I
want you back in 2022. the chemistry
between Ellis and Rodriguez will be one
to look out for as they are known for
working within different genres Netflix
is hit or miss with rom-coms these days
but players has a lot of potential
high in the clouds is easily Netflix's
most unique impending release an
animated feature based on a children's
novel co-written by Philip Arda Jeff
Dunbar and Paul McCartney in 2005.
Netflix will release it in collaboration
with gomal sometime this year the books
illustrator Jeff Dunbar worked with
McCartney on the 1984 animated movie
Rupert and the Frog Song behind the
clouds focuses on Woodland an animal
home about to be demolished by humans
whirl a squirrel is left orphaned by the
destruction and goes on an adventure to
find a new place to live his destination
is Animalia a sanctuary for Animals
surprisingly adults the book tackles
themes of War loss and companionship and
the movie adaptation should do the same
the adaptation has been in development
off and on since 2013 with a number of
filmmakers in the mix to direct
officially Head Over Heels Creator
Timothy record will Helm the film with a
script written by John croker McCartney
will compose songs and an original score
while also executive producing Beatles
fan and animation Buffs alike are sure
to adore this film another addition to
the still growing Legacy of McCartney
one of the world's greatest rock stars
in another comic book adaptation for
Netflix Jim Mickel co-creator of the
streaming Titan Show's Sweet Tooth will
direct his own rendition of Donnie
cates's God country legendary pictures
is attached to the film which marks
another collaboration with Netflix after
the hit films in Ola homes and Enola
homes 2 released in 2020 and 2022
respectively I'm a detective
I am a decipher and I am a finder of
Lost Souls God country follows Emmett
Quinlan a widower battling dementia
Emmett struggles with confusion which
often leads to Violent outbursts that
get him in trouble with local police and
estrange him from his family after a
tornado destroys his home in West Texas
Emmett is thought to be lost and
possibly dead in the debris instead the
disaster renders him cured and an
enchanted sword he found in the eye of
the storm gives him superhuman strength
far from the worlds of DC and Marvel God
country aims to be a refreshing entry in
the superhero genre not kicks no cast
list or plot for the film have yet been
released but Netflix aims to deliver it
to audiences by the end of 2023
based on the BBC psychological Thriller
of the same name Netflix will be
releasing a film adaptation of Luther in
March written by series Creator Neil
cross and directed by Jamie Payne Luther
will as star Idris Elba noted in a
conversation with Empire peel the onion
back on the character of Luther and
broaden the scope Beyond just the gritty
Streets of London
if you take me down I'll take you down
even fast doesn't even order
Luther enters an elite company of
television shows turned into movies
joining Charlie's Angels the X-Files and
Star Trek among countless others elbow
will reprise the title role of Luther a
police detective who has to balance the
horrors of his job with the genius of
his procedural methods Andy Circus and
Cynthia arivo are set for supporting
roles over the course of five seasons
Luther was well received by audiences
and critics alike a BBC fan favorite
Luther should make for a solid film
adaptation especially with the show's
Creator in charge of shaping the plot
directed by George C Wolf the sharp eye
behind 2020's ma rainey's black bottom
Rustin is a dramatized biopic focused on
the life of gay civil rights activist
Bayard Rustin screenwriter Dustin Lance
Black who won the 2009 Oscar for best
original screenplay for his milk script
is on board to write and Barack and
Michelle Obama's company Higher Ground
will oversee production Rustin is set to
place a big emphasis on rustin's
organization of the 1963 March on
Washington Coleman Domingo who
previously worked with wolf in
mahraini's black bottom is set to play
Rustin Hal Rustin will stack up against
the seemingly never-ending list of
biopics remains to be seen But after his
success with Ma Rainey Wolff appears to
be the perfect man to tell the late
activists story
produced by Todd Phillips Martin
Scorsese and Steven Spielberg Hollywood
star Bradley Cooper will direct Maestro
a biopic about composer and humanitarian
Leonard Bernstein Cooper co-wrote the
movie with Josh singer who won an Oscar
for best original screenplay in 2015 for
his Spotlight script leave something for
the rest of us Bradley Cooper in
addition to directing Cooper will play
Bernstein with the film set to focus on
the composer's life especially his
marriage to Felicia montesligre an
actress who later became an anti-war
advocate during the Vietnam war Kerry
Mulligan will take on the role of
matligre a terrific Supporting Cast is
already in place with Jeremy Strong Matt
Bomer Maya Hawk and Sarah Silverman set
to appear Cooper's choice to use the
prosthetic nose in his portrayal of
Bernstein has been met with a great deal
of criticism Canadian Jewish news
reporter James Hirsch proclaimed that
Cooper should not be playing Bernstein
at all if he is unable to do so without
the fake nose a practical effect that
plays negatively into cultural
caricatures of Jewish people Maestro
will certainly generate Buzz come award
season but not without its controversies
being held up to the light first
after helming the BBC film marvelous
Julian farino is returning to the
director's chair for our man from Jersey
Mark Wahlberg is set to start coming off
his performance in Father stew in 2022
the last time we saw Wahlberg's co-star
Halle Berry was in the 2022 box office
disaster moonfall you are the
unidentified Source oh yes
our man from Jersey tells the story of a
blue-collar man becoming a hero
overnight Wahlberg's character Mike is a
construction worker at least until his
high school girlfriend Roxanne played by
Barry convinces him to become a spy Mike
is a nice guy who doesn't have any
interest in turning to the world of
Espionage but it's not long before a Do
or Die Mission leaves him with no choice
JK Simmons Jackie Earle Haley Jessica
dugu and Wale akinu yagbaje and Alice
Lee round out the cast but few other
details have been released by Netflix so
far
not much is known about reptile yet
other than the fact that Grant singers
lead it to direct and the cast is full
of names audiences likely wouldn't
expect to see come together in the same
movie reptile Mark Singer's future film
debut though he spent the last nine
years directing music videos for Sam
Smith the weekend Ariana Grande and
Troye Sivan reptile revolves around a
man named Nichols played by Benicio del
Toro who's a New England detective
working a mysterious case that quickly
bleeds into his own personal life the
lines for nickels are blurred as he
often can't tell what's real and what's
not which leads him down a dark path the
cast is brimming with big names
including Francis Fisher Alicia
Silverstone Justin Timberlake Eric
bogosian Sky Ferreira and Michael Pitt
reptile will Mark a reunion between
Silverstone and Del Toro who played each
other's love interest in excess baggage
in 1997. the Spy Kids franchise is one
of the most successful live-action kids
movie series of all time grossing over
550 million dollars worldwide over the
course of four films Spy Kids has
remained dormant for 12 years ever since
Creator Robert Rodriguez aimed to shift
the Storey's Focus away from Carmen and
Juni Cortez the star of the first three
films
[Music]
Spy Kids Armageddon is meant to be a
total reboot of the series and Rodriguez
has written the script and will be
serving as director the film will focus
on how children are unintentionally
helping a game developer take over the
world through a destructive computer
virus and must then take matters into
their own hands in order to save their
families the cast is led by Gina
Rodriguez and Zachary Levi while Everly
cargonea Connor asterson Billy Magnuson
and DJ catroda round out the Ensemble
don't go into Spy Kids Armageddon
expecting it to be the Citizen Kane of
kids Espionage movies it probably won't
Dazzle critics but it'll be an
action-packed adventure for families on
movie night
Society of the snow is said to be one of
the most dynamic films of 2023 the only
Spanish language entry on the list
Society of the snow is an adaptation of
Pablo verici's book the snow Society the
definitive account of the world's
greatest Survival Story which details
the experiences of the 16 survivors from
the Angie's flight disaster in 1972.
therechu's book is particularly
emotional as the author knew many of the
survivors as a child and felt a
particular connection to them J.A boyona
will translate verichi's story and
documentation onto the screen the story
of the Andes flight disaster is
legendary for how unfathomable the
chances were that anyone could withstand
the mountain range's treacherous
conditions for 72 days as well as the
fact that the survivors were forced to
resort to cannibalism or starve as our
friends were dying they made us realize
that we had an opportunity that they
didn't that we had the responsibility to
live for them
the cast comprises mostly newcomers who
don't have any credits to their name but
interestingly Carlos Perez one of the
real-life survivors of the flight and
the youngest passenger on the plane will
play his own father in the film
directed by MCU alums Anthony and Joe
Russo the electric state is an
adaptation of Simon stalinhog's graphic
novel Christopher Marcus and Stephen
mcfeely the brains behind The Chronicles
of Narnia and Captain America franchises
penned the script while horror
filmmakers Andy and Barbara musketti are
slated to produce not many details about
the film have been announced beyond the
prolific ensemble cast but the premise
is set to focus on Michelle a young girl
who looks for her missing and estranged
brother who has sent her a robot from
some great unknown place the electric
state will be half live action and half
animated frequent Netflix collaborator
Millie Bobby Brown is set to play the
lead role of Michelle while Chris Pratt
Stanley Tucci Jason Alexander Brian Cox
Giancarlo Esposito and Anthony Mackey
are among the names rounding out the
cast be on the lookout for kehi Kwan who
is Fresh Off His Brilliant return to
acting in everything everywhere all at
once which has made him the best
supporting actor favorite at the 2023
Academy Awards
after ceasing production on his hit
series mind Hunter to create the
Blockbuster biopic mank in 2020 David
Fincher has returned to Netflix to
direct the killer an adaptation of
Alexis Nolan's graphic novel series of
the same name Fincher has been attached
to Nolan's books since his early as 2007
the project bouncing from various
production companies before landing at
Netflix's feet only Michael Fassbender
and Tilda Swinton have been announced as
principal cast members audiences last
Saw Fassbender in 2019 when he played
Magneto in X-Men dark Phoenix Swinton
had a busy 2022 as she performed in 3000
years of longing and the Eternal
daughter as well as voicing the role of
the Wood Sprite in Guillermo Dan Toros
Pinocchio to save you he became a real
boy
and real boys
don't come back
Nolan's series tells the story of a
nameless assassin who makes calculated
decisions quietly later revealed to be
named Christian he doesn't have many
goals except for making enough money to
retire and leave the public eye
completely Nolan's work is meant to test
the limits in which audiences can feel
empathy for a bad person if any director
is capable of making that premise work
on the big screen it's Fincher who found
great success with dark brutal dramas
including Fight Club zodiac and Gone
Girl
audiences haven't seen Anthony Stacy in
the director's chair since 2014 when he
co-directed The Box Trolls with Graham
animal first things first off with box
known mostly for his work behind the
camera stouchy has built a long-storied
career as a storyboard artist and visual
effects Creator he got his start on Back
to the Future in 1985 and has since
worked on projects as varied as hook
James and the Giant Peach ants and ghost
The Monkey King focuses on the titular
Monkey King who must travel near and far
to get his staff back from The Wretched
Dragon King screenwriter Stephen
benchich who wrote Brother Bear Chicken
Little and Open Season penned the script
his first since cats and dogs the
Revenge of Kitty Galore in 2010 The
Monkey King Mark spencich and stachi's
first collaboration since 2006. a great
cast is already in place featuring BD
Wong Jimmy o Yang Bowen Yang and
Stephanie Shu The Monkey King will Mark
the first performance for Shu after
everything everywhere all at once which
is putting her in the conversation for
best supporting actress at the Academy
Awards as per variety Matt charman is
back for his first feature film since
2015 when he wrote the script for Steven
Spielberg's Bridge of spies with the
Coen Brothers Charmin secured an Oscar
nomination for best original screenplay
but has been awfully quiet since
charmin's new movie the mothership
follows a single mother Sarah played by
Halle Berry and her kids who stumble
upon an extraterrestrial on their
property Sarah's husband disappeared
without a trace a year earlier and she
believes her new discovery will help
bring him or the truth of his
whereabouts home this Mark Sperry's
second collaboration with Netflix in
2023 along with our man from Jersey in
which she Stars alongside Mark Wahlberg
Molly Parker Amari Hardwick and Sydney
lemon are among the names that will
round up the cast Parker is set to have
a strong 2023 as she will also play Mary
darling in Disney's Peter Pan and Wendy
Hardwick was last seen in the TV series
pieces of her while lemon appeared in
tar alongside Kate Blanchett a release
date hasn't been set yet but expect the
mothership to arrive sometime in late
[Music]
foreign